hey guys Ryan right here can't sleep so
the setter to watch some trailers catch
up here and I figure if I can't go to
sleep what better trailer start off my
night with then the evil within
nothing like demons and good horror to
put you to sleep a survival horror game
I heard the original title or at least a
Japanese title for this is psycho break
which is what I would call my
ex-girlfriend once a month you know what
I mean period yeah so this is like a
survival horror game where I don't know
anything about it I'm fine
trying to come across like I do but
horror freaks me out or is it's quite
terrifying horror is um well well my
ex-girlfriend had once a month Peggy 18
oh my god
[ __ ] is that
hahaha
and it's nothing
has some [ __ ] up [ __ ] right there yeah
I hope that's the right trailer it
didn't look like a video game much to me
but that is pretty scary I mean if the
game feels at all like that it's gonna
be one big creep fest and I can't wait
to check it out I think it's coming out
like in October or something yeah I
thought it dealt with like a detective
or some [ __ ] I don't know what I just
saw but as strangely uncomfortable the
whole time I mean if this game is able
to mix like strong levels of fear with
awesome strategy you know like that's
like the best type of horror survival
game you know like of course what else
is supposed to be you know anything with
demons or supernatural [ __ ] freaks me
out I grew up Catholic no matter how
strong my belief is and all that stuff I
still will always get [ __ ] freaked out
by like anything with supernatural like
that's spider lady with the blood that's
what came out of my ex-girlfriend want
some fun well thank you guys for letting
me know about that trailer I'm so happy
I watched that if you're new to the
channel you can click right here to
subscribe
it'd be good for you if you have
erectile dysfunction it is especially
good for you at this time of the video
I'd like to give some shoutouts but
before I do shoutouts there's a man
named muffin man and this guy he
comments a lot I think he's a subscriber
but he's always insulting me last
comment he made was hit the gym you fat
[ __ ] well I'll have you know I have been
hitting the gym lately muffin man I'm
planning on losing a bunch of weight I'm
gonna get sexy I'm gonna piss on your
dead corpse you [ __ ] [ __ ] and why
are you dead because I [ __ ] killed
you with my new biceps choke you to
death anyway the gaming Rhino he's been
waiting for a shoutout for a while well
gaming Rhino you're getting one Rhino
rhinos are impressive creatures they for
some reason what I immediately think of
is Jim Carrey and Ace Ventura too when
he's coming out of the Rhinos ass that's
what I'm gonna think about every time I
think of you man brandy
Dickie Ryan give me a shout-out and make
fun of my name please
Brandon Dickie I don't I don't know
where I can make fun of your name
there's there's nothing funny about your
name Brandon very common name Dickie I
mean I feel like you want me to make a
sex show here but I just don't get where
I can make a dick joke here mr. Dickey
my Dickies afraid of my ex-girlfriend
what I don't know I keep doing this
stupid joke 95 he wants a shout-out this
guy frequent commenter has subscribed
for a while and he's really perverted
actually very perverted you stay that
way because clearly we need perverts in
our life otherwise we can't appreciate
people who are not perverts so we need
balance good and evil you know what I
mean
girly evil within pervert he actually
said I wants a shout outs
you want some multiple shout outs let's
see what I can do hey Mike
you only shout out hello oh shut up all
right Sean you're gonna be getting a
shout-out from me I'm going to go after
me lucky charms cuz this is the most
stereotypical Irish accent I could do
all right so what am i you are going to
get a shout out amen you want to shout
out and say well I'm gonna give you a
man LOC aurita you deserve the most
wonderful shout out in the world oh you
stupid American liberal deserter of a
shout out
where's the shout out yo huh you wanna
[ __ ] shut up
are you dumb son of a [ __ ] show yeah we
add the wine you want a [ __ ] shadow
you [ __ ] you bloom Johnny Depp and
I'm here today to do 95 shadow yeah